- Thanks to Brilliant for
keeping Legal Eagle in the air.
Get 20% off your annual subscription
by using the link in the description.
The coronavirus is now officially killed
more people than SARS, and
it shows no sign of stopping.
And it's not clear that the US government
is actually prepared for this.
The Department of Homeland Security
is falsely saying that the mortality rate
of COVID-19 is comparable
to that of the flu.
- Worldwide I believe it's under 2%.
- What's the mortality rate for influenza,
over the last say 10 years in America?
- It's also right around
that percentage as well.
- Actually the flu is
20 times less deadly,
and recently Vice President Mike Pence
was put in charge of the
government's response.
Worse, there were reports of entire cities
being quarantined in China
and across the globe.
But that's not America, right?
Have you ever had a nightmare
about being permanently
confined to your house?
Can you imagine one day waking
up to find police officers
and soldiers right
outside your front door,
refusing to let you leave?
That could never happen in America,
in response to a pandemic.
Could it?
(trumpet music)
Hey Legal Eagles it's time
to think like a lawyer
because the world is facing a pandemic.
This is gonna be a bit more speculative
than most of the normal
videos on this channel
because we're going to
explore whether the US
could legally quarantine
towns, cities and states,
the way some other countries are.
You might be surprised to learn
that there is both US precedent,
and law on this subject.
Now as of the time of this video
there are at least 80,000 confirmed cases
of the coronavirus worldwide
and almost 3000 deaths
attributable to the virus,
and the numbers are steadily climbing.
The question is how do you
stop the spread of a disease
or a virus that is asymptomatic?
This is the problem facing
China and the rest of the world.
Now coronavirus is the name
for a large family of viruses
that can cause mild or severe illnesses
in humans and animals.
There are seven different
strains of coronavirus
known to infect humans, and
before this most recent outbreak
only two of the coronaviruses were known
to cause serious illness.
You might recognize them MERS and SARS.
So what the heck is
this newest coronavirus?
Well officially it's called 2019-nCoV,
and it hasn't been extensively studied.
Doctors don't know where it came from,
most coronaviruses are
transmitted to humans
through an intermediate host.
With SARS, the host was palm civets.
For MERS, the host was
identified as camels.
The host for the 2019 coronavirus
has not yet been identified,
but according to researchers
at Johns Hopkins,
it may have come from bats.
Doctors are still working to understand
the 2019 coronavirus disease symptoms,
course and severity.
Traditional flu symptoms like runny nose,
sore throat and vomiting
have only been reported
by about 2% of infected patients.
Common symptoms seem to
include shortness of breath,
fever and cough.
But the problem with the 2019 coronavirus
is that people can spread the virus
before they're even symptomatic.
So far almost 80,000 cases of coronavirus
have been reported in China
with about 14% classified as severe.
Now, the first known
patient developed symptoms
as early as December,
although China alerted the
World Health Organization
by the end of 2019,
China didn't act according
to lockdown the city of Wuhan
until January 23.
At first, every patient's blood test
had to be transmitted to Beijing,
which slowed diagnosis and analysis,
and the hospitals quickly became
overwhelmed and overcrowded.
It appears the Chinese government
didn't want people to panic,
but withholding information
is rarely a good idea
in situations like these.
Chinese physician Li Wenliang
and his fellow doctors
raced to warn the public of
the new coronavirus in 2019,
but the Chinese government
immediately threatened
Dr. Wenliang for spreading false rumors.
Dr. Wenliang has now
died from the very virus
he was working to contain.
This situation has caused
some people to draw analogies
between the way that the
Chinese are responding
to the coronavirus outbreak,
to the way that the Soviet
Union responded to Chernobyl.
When the Soviet nuclear reactor broke down
triggering explosions,
fires and radioactive smoke.
The Soviet government denied
the severity of the accident,
was slow to release
information to the public
and generally screwed
up the entire situation
into a historic tragedy.
So before we talk about
the legality of isolation
and quarantines in the United States,
let's actually talk
about what that entails.
Societies, traditionally
have dealt with pandemics
by isolating people so
that they can prevent
the spread of contagious
disease to other people.
Isolation means separating people
who have a contagious disease
from people who do not.
Quarantine takes the
isolation one step further.
Quarantine separates out people
with a contagious disease
and restricts the movement of people
who have been exposed
to contagious diseases,
to see if they get sick.
In either case, the goal is to stop
person-to-person
transmission of a disease.
So what gives the government the right
to quarantine in the first place?
Isolation and quarantine
are not just medical terms.
The government has generally speaking,
what's called police power
to sometimes in an emergency
legally isolate and quarantine patients.
Police power in this context
means that the government
has a right to enforce laws,
protect public welfare health and safety.
If we're talking about
the federal government
then many legal scholars believe
that police power is implied
in the Commerce Clause
to the Constitution.
And in fact, by the time that
the constitution was drafted,
the US had already used quarantine powers
to deal with several public health crises.
In the modern era the
federal law governing
isolation and quarantine
is found in Section 361
of the Public Health Service Act.
This law authorizes the
US Secretary of Health
and Human Services to take
measures to prevent the entry
and spread of communicable
diseases, into the United States
and between the states.
In fact, as is currently on the books,
federal isolation and quarantine
is currently authorized
for a list of contagious diseases
including cholera, diphtheria,
infectious tuberculosis,
plague, smallpox, yellow fever,
viral hemorrhagic fevers,
severe acute respiratory syndromes,
and flu that can cause a pandemic.
In order to keep this list flexible,
the President has the
power to revise this list
through executive order.
But if quarantine and
isolation is necessary,
how would the government
carry out that order?
Well, under federal law
the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention or CDC,
has the right to issue an
isolation or a quarantine order.
State and tribal governments
may issue their own orders
and ask federal authorities
for help enforcing them.
And if necessary, the US
Customs and Border Patrol
and US Coast Guard may be
asked to enforce those orders.
So the question is, is the US government
using isolation and quarantine now?
Well, you may be pleased
or terrified to know
that the US has actually now issued
its first quarantine order in 50 years.
Recently health officials have quarantined
the 195 Americans who
were evacuated from Wuhan.
All 195 people must remain
at the March Air Reserve Base
in California during the
incubation period of 14 days.
20 doctors and nurses at the base
will monitor the passengers.
If any of them starts to get sick
they will be transferred to a hospital.
And in fact patients in New
York, Los Angeles and Chicago
are being monitored
for signs of the virus.
And the Trump administration
recently announced
they will be suspending the
entry of any foreign national
who has traveled to China
over the last two weeks,
unless they are immediate
family of a US citizen.
In addition, any US citizen
who has been in China's
Hubei province within the last 14 days
of their return will be
subject to up to 14 days
of mandatory quarantine to ensure
that they are provided medical care
and healthcare screening.
According to the DHS order,
air travelers without an nexus to China
may also be routed to one of 11 airports
if they discover mid-flight
that someone on board has been
to China in the last 14 days.
This might be completely necessary
but the history of
isolation and quarantine
in the United States
raises a lot of questions.
But this is America, damn
it, and if there's one thing
that Americans like to
do, it's to sue people.
So the question is,
could you as an American
sue the government over
a quarantine order,
and if you did what kind of
rights do you have to challenge
what happens to you during confinement?
Well the answer to that question,
depends on what kind of disease you have,
whether the government
is acting arbitrarily,
and what era you live in.
So let's talk about the legal history
of isolation and quarantine
in the United States.
The first era of quarantine
law runs from the colonial days
to the late 19th century, at
that time infectious diseases
were a deadly serious
threat to public health,
so it's probably not surprising
that there are a few cases challenging
the government's broad
authority to detain and restrain
individuals who were infected
or exposed to communicable diseases.
In 1793, 5000 people died in Philadelphia
from yellow fever alone.
Philadelphia was the
nation's capital at the time
and federal officials
evacuated and left the city
to deal with the fallout.
So many people died that the city
lost a 10th of its population
and the city government
effectively collapsed.
The quarantine order sent
patients to a hospital
in the country, but it
wasn't very effective
since yellow fever is
spread through mosquitoes.
The crisis ended finally
when the weather turned cold
and killed off the mosquitoes.
Similarly, the New York typhus
outbreak of 1892 started
when certain immigrants
arrived in Ellis Island.
Many of the passengers were
sick with typhus fever.
By the time the illness developed
most immigrants had already
settled on the Lower East Side
in New York City.
The government rounded up those immigrants
and quarantine them on
North Brother Island.
The incident provoked racist
and anti-semitic hysteria
in the newspapers.
And then there's of course,
the famous eponymous Typhoid Mary,
the nickname for a cook, Mary Mallon.
Mary was an Irish immigrant
who carried the bacteria
that causes typhus fever.
Mallon was actually immune to the disease
but that didn't stop the disease
from spreading to others.
And by working as a cook,
Mary Mallon had spread
a form of the salmonella disease
to people all over the city.
Police also sent her
to North Brother Island
to avoid communicating it to other people.
So Typhoid Mary's term of confinement
was supposed to be three years
as long as she agreed
never to work as a cook,
however Mallon later
resumed her work as a cook
and started another outbreak in 1915.
Authorities again tracked her down
and sent her back to the
island for 23 more years.
During this period quarantine was seen
as the ultimate public good.
The Supreme Court said
that involuntary quarantine
was constitutional in a case that involved
quarantine of passengers from
eastern and southern Europe
on the Britannia.
American and Louisiana authorities
stopped passengers from leaving the ship
despite no evidence that anyone
had a contagious disease.
The court said that the government
could hold the passengers indefinitely
because immigrants were on board
and of course immigrants carry diseases.
Not really the courts finest moment
of constitutional analysis.
During this period courts
reviewed a lot of quarantine cases
but mostly they just checked
to see if the government
was following its own rules.
It helps that the diseases
that people were worried about
were all highly communicable,
like yellow fever, typhus and smallpox.
Moreover, almost everyone living
in the 18th and 19th centuries
had lost someone to communicable disease,
since there were few effective treatments.
If a city like Philadelphia
could lose 10% of its population
very quickly, then communicable diseases
were seen as threats analogous to war.
Americans would have to
wait until the second era
of quarantine cases to
challenge the validity
of involuntary separation and quarantine.
In 1900, California federal court
became the first appeals court
to reject a quarantine law
on racial grounds.
The city of San Francisco
issued an order requiring
all Chinese residents to be vaccinated
against bubonic plague.
The inoculations turned out to be tainted.
But the city argued that bubonic plague
was a serious problem
and that Asians as a race
were more likely to carry that disease.
The California Court struck down that law
because it violated the
Equal Protection Clause.
It discriminated against Asian immigrants
and the city also couldn't
back up its claims
that the inoculation could stop the spread
of the diseases it was targeting.
Of course, that didn't stop
the San Francisco health officials
who tried it a second time.
This time, claiming that nine people died
from bubonic plague and that
the only way to contain it
was by quarantining people who
lived in Asian neighborhoods.
At the same time, the city gave exemptions
to people who were not Asian
but lived in those neighborhoods.
Appropriately the angry
federal district court
struck down this quarantine law as well.
The key takeaway from these cases
is that if the government is reacting
to communicable diseases, the
threat had better be real.
The government's action
can't just be an excuse
for discrimination.
In the 20th century though
the government still found ways to take
its quarantine and isolation
powers in new directions.
The first target was prostitution.
The idea was that prostitutes
spread the sexually transmitted diseases
and should be isolated and quarantined.
The medical examinations
for venereal diseases
were more invasive of personal privacy.
Police took advantage
of this quarantine power
and arrested and detained prostitutes
for reasons unrelated to
communicable diseases.
And of course, there was stigma
towards anyone who was quarantined
for having a venereal disease.
This was a monumental shift
in how public health officials
conceptualize power to
stop contagious diseases.
But this new relationship
between public health
and criminal law forced courts
to give personal freedom,
a more serious look.
The California Courts were
the first in the country
to establish what the
government needed to prove
to detain someone who had
a communicable disease.
At a bare minimum the
government had to establish
some reasonable ground to
believe that the targeted person
had been exposed or infected
with a contagious disease.
Of course at the same time,
people were facing real
risks from pandemics.
The influenza pandemic of 1917 and 1919,
killed around 50 million people.
It resulted in mass quarantine orders
in bands of public gatherings,
and unfortunately the
isolation and quarantines
did little to stop the spread of disease.
Influenza was highly contagious with
people becoming infected after exposure
of just a few minutes.
But given the danger
and the high death rate,
no serious legal challenges
seem to have been
brought during this time.
People were really just
trying to survive a world war
and global pandemic at the same time.
So the question is can you challenge
a quarantine order
today and could you stop
a quarantine in the United States?
Certainly modern medicine has progressed
a long way since 1917.
Well the answer is probably yes,
you can challenge it depending
on the circumstances.
The Constitution says,
"The privilege of the
writ of habeas corpus
"shall not be suspended, unless
when in cases of rebellion
"or invasion the public
safety may require it."
Generally this means that
a person has the right
to petition the court if
they are illegally confined.
This procedure is used most often
to challenge a criminal conviction,
but it also applies to quarantine cases.
That being said, it's not often easy
to win a habeas case.
In 2014, Thomas Eric Duncan,
the first man in America
to be diagnosed with Ebola died
after Dallas hospital failed to recognize
the signs of the disease.
They sent him home with
a sinusitis diagnosis
and his fiance Louise Troh,
experienced the nightmare scenario
I discussed at the beginning of the video.
She woke up one day to a
court order and armed guards
posted outside of her apartment.
Troh and her family were
confined for 14 days
and then sent into a Catholic Cottage
for the remainder of a 21 day order.
After Duncan's death, Troh's
apartment was fumigated
and many of her
possessions were destroyed.
Troh was left homeless
after several landlords
denied her rental applications.
Troh didn't actually
challenge the order in court
but her case illustrates how
restrictive of personal freedom
quarantine and isolation can be,
limiting a person's
ability to travel, work
and to find a place to live.
And it's very difficult to
overturn one of these orders,
you have to show that the government
is acting in an arbitrary
and capricious manner.
The Florida Supreme Court
set the state standard
for reasonableness of a
state quarantine order
in a 1956 case called Moore versus Draper.
There the plaintiff had
challenged his quarantine
for tuberculosis.
The Florida court said that quote,
"The constitutional
guarantees of life, liberty,
"and property of which a
person cannot be deprived
"without due process of law,
"do not limit the exercise
of the police power
"of the state to preserve
the public health,
"so long as that power is
reasonably and fairly exercised
"and not abused."
Although federal courts are not bound
by the Florida Supreme Court's decision,
its statement of the law is regarded
as the general standard for determining
whether a person's due
process rights were violated.
The decision gives great weight
to the government's determination
that the public health,
really is at stake.
And to bring it back
to the current pandemic
that we're faced with,
in our current scenario,
this wouldn't be a hard standard
for the government to meet.
Coronavirus 2019 is still spreading.
People are still dying and researchers
don't have a firm handle
on the disease yet.
Though there are other issues
about how far authorities
can push their quarantine
and isolation orders,
generally a person in a
civil confinement context
like isolation or quarantine
should be free from physical restraint.
But if you were subject to
isolation showing no symptoms
of infection and you tried to leave,
could authorities actually restrain you?
According to the Supreme Court,
the answer is probably yes,
if you are quote, "a dangerous patient."
Again, it's pretty easy
for the state to prove
that a person is dangerous
if they are contagious.
Authorities only needs
to show that the reason
for the restraint and
confinement is not arbitrary,
but that's not to say
that there aren't cases
where the government
has acted unreasonably.
For example in 2007,
the ACLU challenged a
dangerous patient determination
on behalf of Robert Daniels,
a quarantined tuberculosis patient
who emigrated from Russia to Arizona.
Daniels had been diagnosed
with dangerous TB
and when Daniels defined a court order
requiring him to wear
a face mask he refused,
leading to his arrest and confinement
in the Maricopa County Jail.
Maricopa County Sheriff Joe Arpaio,
you might remember that guy,
kept Daniels in solitary
confinement for nearly a year.
After the ACLU lawsuit the
county transferred Daniels
to national Jewish hospital
where physicians determined
that he actually didn't have
dangerous and contagious TB.
After which Daniel's returned to Russia,
Arpaio was later convicted
of criminal contempt
for ignoring a court order
in a separate matter.
Donald Trump then pardoned Arpaio
and they all live happily ever after.
- I stand by my partner Sheriff Joe--
- And as for whether the US government
could affect a nation
or statewide quarantine,
well, the government has wide latitude
to isolate and quarantine anyone
who has been in the area of Wuhan
over the last couple of months.
But for better or worse,
generally the isolation
and quarantine orders
can't last longer than
the incubation period
of the targeted disease.
The CDC currently estimates
that the incubation period
is about 14 days for the 2019 coronavirus
based on previous iterations, like MERS.
Of course, the reason
governments resort to quarantine
is because the virus tends
to spread exponentially.
If you want to follow in the footsteps
of heroic doctors like Dr. Wenliang,
today's sponsor Brilliant
can help you learn to think
like a scientist and get a
handle on practical math.
Brilliant is all about teaching
you to think through math,
science and computer science problems
on a deeper level,
all while building stronger
and universally applicable
cognitive skills along the way.
One of my favorite courses
is all about logic.
Brilliant's logic courses covers
liar and truth teller riddles,
logical fallacies, machine logic
and even some strategic game theory.
Logic is a crucial skill that lawyers
and even our arch nemesis,
doctors need every day.
Brilliant lets you learn by
doing, rather than listening
to hours of boring lectures.
Learning through doing
is scientifically proven
to be the most effective
way to master any new skill.
And in fact, I recommend learning by doing
to my law students for just this reason.
Are you in school right now?
Do you want to be a doctor or a nurse?
The skills that you learn with Brilliant
will help you on your way.
Within Brilliant's Library
you'll find courses and topics
like calculus, linear algebra and math,
that applies to trading and finance.
You'll also find courses
on gravitational physics,
astronomy and machine learning.
And you can level up in
just five minutes a day
by working on the daily challenge.
Each daily challenge
provides you with a context
and framework that you
need to challenge it,
so you don't have to take a
deep dive if you don't want to.
You can sign up and
start learning for free
today at Brilliant.org/LegalEagle
and the first 200 people who sign up
will also get 20% off
their annual subscription.
So just click on the
link in the description
to get 20% off of your
subscription to Brilliant.
Plus clicking on the link
really helps out the channel.
So, do you agree with my analysis,
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
where I explore all of the
other legal issues of the day,
including others speculative legal topics.
So click on this playlist,
and I'll see you in court.